COLT MCANLIS: Hey, game devs.
Ever notice that after a user
switches from another app back
to your game, the
entire world explodes?
That's due to
OpenGL context loss,
and it's a process
in Android that
can be maddening if
not handled correctly.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
I'm here with a few simple tips
to make the recovering from
a context loss a lot easier.
Firstly, you have to understand
that OpenGL context loss can
happen for any
number of reasons.
For example, when the
user rotates their phone,
or they get a call,
or any time they
swap to and from your game.
And what makes GL
context loss so difficult
is that any resources you have
on the GPU-- like textures,
vertex buffers,
and the like-- are
invalidated when the
context loss occurs, which
means any references you had
to those objects in your game
are now invalid as well.
The objects just
don't exist anymore.
Properly recovering
from a context loss
is a two-step process.
First, you have to detect
when a context loss occurs
and properly recover the basic
OpenGL states to put it back
in order.
Second, you need to then go
through and recreate any GPU
assets that you might
need for your game.
So let's start at the top.
Detecting when a
context loss occurs
is an extremely easy process.
Typically at the end of
your rendering frame,
you make a call to
EGL Swap Buffers
in order to signal OpenGL to
move ahead with the next frame.
When a loss occurs,
The Swap Buffer call
will return an EGL
false value to let
you know that something
has gone wrong.
And in true GL
fashion, you can then
get the reason for
the context loss
by immediately
calling GL Get Error.
The returning enum
will let you know
if you've lost your display,
surface, or context objects.
These three objects-- surface,
display, and context--
are created when you
first initialize OpenGL,
and each comes with their own
create and destroy methods,
which is very, very important
on the Android platform.
Each object can be lost
independently of the others,
and should be recovered
independently from the others
after a loss has occurred.
Trying to recover all
three at the same time
is simply going to
drive you insane.
So when you've been notified
that an object has been lost,
the first thing you need to
do is go ahead and properly
call the destroy
method for that object,
and then send it back
to its default state.
This process will
make sure everything
is cleaned up properly.
Oh, and it's a really good
idea to set a global flag
that details that your
context has been lost that
will help us in the recovery
of this state later.
Now that we've
detected a context loss
and properly invalidated
the object responsible,
it's actually time
to recover the lost
object in the same fashion.
The best place to
recover these objects
is at the beginning
of your render frame
before you go off and do
any of your draw calls.
It's pretty straightforward
at this point.
Since we invalidated our
objects in the previous frame,
we simply need to
check which objects
are in the invalid
state and directly call
their initialization functions.
And once you've detected
that all of your objects
have been restored, you can
then reattach GL to the context
and surface by calling
EGL Make Current.
Oh, and you can also flip your
context loss flag back to false
at this point, because
everything has been recovered
and you're good to go.
Now, it's worth pointing
out one caveat here.
There's a tad bit of a temporal
quality to this whole process
that you could be receiving
Render Frame calls
before the system is ready to
allow you to actually recover
from a context loss.
As such, calls to the Create
Functions for your GL objects
will fail until things
have actually settled down.
If this is the case,
the best thing to do
is simply break out of
your Render function
and keep trying each
subsequent frame
to recover until the system
has actually settled down.
So that OpenGL is properly
recovered after a loss,
it's time for the really
hard part-- recreating
your game's GPU resources.
The reason that
this is so difficult
is that typically,
game developers
bundle initialization
of their GPU assets
alongside initialization
of the systems
that they correspond to.
For example, loading
a map file usually
requires you to read the
map data off of disk,
find some texture
information in it,
load that texture
into CPU memory,
and then copy that
into GPU memory.
When a loss occurs, the textures
that the map references are now
invalid, and the only
path to recreate them
requires going back through
and reloading the map object.
In reality, this is a bad
idea, and it will only
lead you into the
valley of madness.
The correct thing to
do here is twofold.
Firstly, you need to add a
manager system to resources
and assets that you
load off of disk.
For example, rather than
going directly to disk
to load a texture, instead,
create a texture manager system
to do that work for you.
The manager system should
define an object that
holds the GL handle as well
as a path to the file on disk.
The manager will handle loading
of the texture off of disk
and creating the GPU
resources on your behalf.
This does create a
little bit of overhead,
though, as you want to
pass back the Managed
handle to the texture rather
than the OpenGL one, which you
can easily transfer for
later with a different API.
To make the assets
systems fully work,
you need to support the second
step of our process, which
is allowing a function chain
that can destroy and create
the resources on demand.
Since your asset manager is
keeping around the file names,
you can easily go back and
recreate any GPU assets
you need once a GL loss
occurs without having
to update the external
systems that might actually
be interfacing with the manager.
Oh, and it also lends itself
to really cool processes,
like being able to detect when
an asset has changed on disk
and automatically
updating it in memory.
But that's a different show.
Anyhow, the last
thing we need to do
is properly support the
Create Destroy cycle
during our GL loss
recovery process.
Firstly, when a GL
context loss is detected,
you want to globally
destroy any existing
handles to graphics objects.
This includes any asset
managers you've created
as well as any
subsystems that might
have static or manually-created
resources as well.
And once GL context loss
is properly recovered,
you can then move
forward with recreating
all of your game's
GPU resources.
And with that, everything should
be back up and running again.
To understand more about
the Android life cycle, hop
on over to the Android
developer site.
And don't forget to check out
Google Play Games services
examples, which includes other
great tricks for handling
NDK apps on Android.
Now, by properly
recovering a context loss
and adding an adaptive model
for recreating your GPU assets,
you'll be creating a stable
environment for your users
so that they can get back to
the really important stuff--
killing zombies.
Thanks for watching.